Bonnie writes 10-year stint as the
world's favorite wizard Kid Sister
turned her into a plastic hating theater
loving mother sometimes growing up can
be a magical thing Bonnie Wright started
casting her spell on the big screen in
2001's Harry Potter and the Sorcerer
Stone appearing as Jenny Weasley as her
older brothers and Harry Bor the
Hogwarts Express she joins them at
Hogwarts A year later in Harry Potter
and the Chamber of Secrets which finds
her being controlled by Tom Riddle later
revealed to be a younger version of Lord
Voldemort jinny is briefly spotted in
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of aaban
and Harry Potter in the goblet of fire
her character becomes a steady presence
as she builds her relationship with
Harry Wright also noted that her one
line in Harry Potter and the Sorcerer of
stone wasn't added until they went to
film the train station scene that helps
catapult Harry into his first Wizarding
Adventure the completed scene shows
Jenny wishing Harry well the suggestion
made by director Chris Columbus walk
straight at the wall between platform
for was 9 and 10 best do it at a bit of
a run if you're nervous good luck great
like most of the cast grew up on the
Harry Potter set and as she became a
young woman so did Jenny in the Order of
the Phoenix she joins the group at the
department of mysteries where Harry
learns about the prophecy that sets him
against Voldemort and she gets to show
her tough Side by using an impressive
reducto spell against the deatheaters
pursuing them wri's role is greatly
expanded in the halfblood prince getting
just as much screen time as she did in
the second film she now plays a
confident young woman who has friends a
boyfriend and a place in the slug Club
probably her most vital role in the film
is her relationship with Daniel
Radcliffe's character after years of
crushing on Harry The Chosen One finally
realizes his feelings and the two begin
to date she Comforts Harry after
Dumbledore's death fights in the Battle
of Hogwarts and watches her own children
head to her Alma moer after Harry Potter
Wright appeared in various Independent
films including three in 20 3 she played
rose in the sea based on the novel by
John banville it features a man's return
to his childhood Beach following the
death of his wife she then played
Georgina an orthopedic surgeon
participating in a what if scenario to
gain entrance to a bunker in the case of
an atomic Apocalypse in the Sci-Fi
psychological Thriller After the Dark
the film was nominated for best motion
picture at the siges film festival known
as the world's top fantasy Film Festival
Wright's final role in 2013 was as
Phoebe before I sleep the movie which
follows a reclusive poet on his search
for peace premiered at the Heartland
film festival in addition to being an
actor wrright has also tried her hand at
directing in 2012 she made her
directoral debut with the student film
separate we come separate we go which
follows a 10-year-old girl meeting and
becoming friends with a widowed man
premiering at the can film festival and
at the Gold Coast International Film
Festival the 12-minute film was well
received she also has directed the short
films know thyself Fade to gold and
Medusa's ankles Wright even has some
music videos under her belt the first of
which being CS by George Schuster she
continued directing music videos in 2018
with taught you how to feel by Sophie
low aiguan Bird by Pete yor and Scarlett
Johansson and fallible by Maguire her
next directing project melt was also for
Maguire and was released in
2021 Wright is an active spokesperson
for environmentalism especially when it
comes to plastic she has raised
awareness about the dangers of plastic
pollution encouraging fans and friends
to stop relying on single-use plastic
she joined Greenpeace in 2017 to
highlight how single-use plastic has
negatively affected our oceans and
Wildlife and the importance of beach
cleanups I was really saddened to find
how much plastic we found just in that
you know small you know an hour's worth
of of trolling she participated in the
fight against the Coca-Cola Company one
of the worst producers of plastic
pollution according to Green Peace to
stop the production of billions of
plastic bottles W said I'm happy to
stand with the more than 585,000 people
who are calling on coch to phase out its
use of throwaway plastic bottles Wright
continues to fight for a cleaner Earth
through social media by promoting
recycled products showing the beauty of
Nature and encouraging followers to take
action in April 2022 Wright added author
to her list of job titles releasing go
gently actionable steps to nurture
yourself and the planet wri shares
sustainable practices that readers can
regular practice at home and those tips
and tricks have now become the
inspiration for a television series
Wright shared the news that she would be
creating a new show on the go gently
website in May 2019 she wrote the
production wrapped in April 2023 she
wrote while sharing photos of her team
surrounded by Nature it was such an
incredible Adventure through California
and Oregon traversing so many different
Landscapes meeting up with so many
incredible humans doing powerful work to
protect our planet as of October 2023 a
premier date has not been announced
announced for those who can't wait for
wr's episodic documentary to Premiere
she does share ways to practice
sustainability via Instagram and YouTube
in 2013 Wright made her theater debut
sharing her acting talents in the play
The Moment of Truth which focuses on a
government that is facing Doom as war is
on the horizon the 2013 production
marked the first time that the play had
been performed in London since 1951
Wright played the role of the girl
during the show's 4-we summer run at the
southw playhouse in London she told
what's on stage that she in no way
resembles her character which is why she
enjoyed playing the part and apparently
theater is something that she has always
wanted to explore she said that she felt
like she was trying to navigate an ocean
during the first few days of rehearsals
adding but I am loving every moment of
the challenge every day I feel like I am
evolving in some way amid her successful
acting career and push to protect the
planet rright is growing her family in
April 2023 she and her husband Andrew
Loko announced that they were expecting
their first child by posting a photo of
the couple on wri's Instagram she wrote
in the post what a wild and humbling
Journey pregnancy is transforming to
make space for new life she has since
been chronicling parts of her pregnancy
on the social media site and posted
videos to her YouTube channel discussing
nesting and how to keep Earth in mind
when it comes to newborn Essentials in
an interview with Brides Wright
explained that she and Loko met at a New
Year's Eve party in 2018 and got engaged
in September 2021 with a ring designed
by her parents Gary Wright and Sheila
Teague who created The Jewelry Company
Wright and Teague Wright and Loko tied
the knot on March 19th 2022 at a
California Farm owned by friends they
focused on using sustainable materials
for the wedding and made a lot of items
themselves she said we loved the idea of
being surrounded by Bountiful growing
nourishing plants as we said we do the
Wizarding World story has since
continued on stage in the play Harry
Potter and the cursed child which
follows the Potter and we Weasley
children as they navigate schoolwork and
evil leading Harry and his friends to
band together to protect their families
the play first premiered on London's
West End in 2016 and headed to
Broadway's Lyric Theater in April 2018
many have wondered if the play will ever
get the big screen treatment right told
the inside of you with Michael rosenbom
podcast that she is interested in
reprising her role in a film adaptation
if the opportunity ever presents itself
noting that she is currently unaware of
such a project being in the works it's
not about our characters so it wouldn't
be a massive role so it would be fun um
I but I have no idea if they'll do it
years after the final Harry Potter film
Wright continues to connect with fans of
the franchise in 2022 she appeared on
the max TV special Harry Potter 20th
anniversary returned to Hogwarts taking
a walk down memory lane with other cast
members to actually get us all in one
place was uh a feat she also stopped by
the updated Warner Brother Studio tour
her Hollywood during a pre-opening visit
in 2021 exploring the Wizarding World
she said while walking through the
magical attraction I was like we were
small we were tiny we were babies it was
a big Revelation Wright has also taken
to social media to share her perspective
on Harry Potter author JK Rowling amid
the controversy surrounding Rowling's
comments against the transgender
community in 2020 she wrote on X if
Harry Potter was a source of love and
belonging for you that love is infinite
and there to take without judgment or
question question trans women are women
I see and love you Bonnie she told the
times in 2022 I made that comment then
and I still stand with that same feeling
but it's got to the point where I prefer
not to comment more it's subject outside
of my input while the movies may be over
Bonnie Wright is still writing this
chapter of her career continuing to work
on different Wizarding World projects
according to the Wizarding World website
Wright is just one of several big names
who lint their voices to the audiobook
version of the tales of beetle The Bard
which is a book made up of five fairy
tales the audio book was released on
Audible in March 2020 while working on
the films Wright also voiced her
character in the video game adaptations
of Harry Potter and the Order of the
Phoenix and Harry Potter and the
halfblood prince she's also been to the
Harry Potter and the Forbidden Journey
attraction at The Wizarding World of
Harry Potter at Universal Studios
Florida in 2014 she took a tour of the
park Diagon Alley with James and Oliver
Phelps who played Fred and George
Weasley the trio were given a look at
all of the magic that fans can explore
in a video posted to the Universal
Orlando resort YouTube
channel